There's several types of mutations we can learn about in this
lesson. And instead of me just telling you what they are. I'd
rather show you and see how good you are on picking up
on exactly what they are. Let's just take this normal human sequence
that I picked randomly from the human genome. Let's make some
changes to this original sequence. And I want to see if you can
match the change that you see over here in the individual sequence
with the type of mutation that we're going to cover in this lesson.
I've numbered the types one through five. When you
think you've matched up the right mutation to the right
sequence here just go ahead and put that number
in the box over here. See how you can do.